(Casting)
The rivalry between KT and SKT, two of South Korea’s largest telecom companies,
is one of the oldest in esports.
Dubbed “The Telecom War,” it has defined generations of players and shaped the history
of entire games.
In Korea, the crucible from which esports emerged, no teams have battled for longer
than SK Telecom T1 and KT Rolster.
It is a battle that has raged for years.
In stadiums, on TV.
The Telecom War was foundational for an industry that, while still niche in the West, was already
in full swing in South Korea.
For SKT, it all began with Lim “Boxer” Yo Hwan, one of the greatest Stacraft: Brood
War players of all time.
(Casting)
Boxer was a godfather of Korean esports, and years later people would call him the first
“Bonjwa.”
It’s a Korean pronoun meant to raise one’s self up that’s used to describe a Starcraft
player who the community agrees is the most dominant player of his era.
Initially, Boxer founded a team named Orion in 2002 and in December 2003, the team’s
name changed to 4 Union.
But in 2004, SK Telecom sponsored the org and SK Telecom T1 was born.
If SKT was built around Boxer in the early 2000s, KT centered around Hong "YellOw" Jin Ho.
Created as Raptors in 1998, the organization became the KTF MagicNs in March 2001.
The org would change its name twice more in 2009 before settling on KT Rolster.
KT became known for their willingness to spend big money on their roster.
YellOw was known for his aggressive Zerg playstyle, and had one of the best ZvTs in the business.
He was a frequent finalist in OSL from 2001-2005, though he never won.
His biggest obstacle?
Boxer.
YellOw and Boxer’s rivalry would become one of the game’s biggest, with KT and SKT’s
stars frequently butting heads on the game’s biggest stages, even before SKT was founded.
And though their lifetime record was fairly close, Boxer always seemed to clinch the matches
that mattered most.
(Casting)
But even as SKT and KT’s players competed for trophies in the individual competitions,
a new battlefield loomed.
One that would become one of Starcraft’s most popular and influential, and one that
would set the framework for modern esports as we know it.
Proleague.
The team-based league became one of the game’s most popular competitive staples, and the
format — which saw both 1v1 and 2v2 matches
— would go on to define the Telecom War.
The format for the 2005 SKY Proleague was simple.
Two rounds, each with a winner, then a Grand Final in which the best teams from both rounds
face off for all the glory.
Since SKT won both Round 1 and Round 2, the top three teams from both played in the Grand
Final tournament.
But the final two teams came down to fate.
Played in front of a packed stadium, the SKY Proleague Grand Finals in 2005 was the biggest
early competition in the Telecom War.
And, much like many battles between SKT and KT that were yet to come, KT couldn’t overcome
their rivals.
(Casting)
After the 2005 finals, both teams entered a period of decline.
KTF’s top players were getting old, and many retired or were forced to enter the Air Force.
In 2006, Boxer announced that he’d also received his draft letter, and would leave
his team for the Air Force.
Then, in 2007, everything changed.
His name is Lee “Flash” Young Ho.
And he is widely seen as the best Starcraft
player of all time.
He was only 14 when he made his professional debut.
(Casting)
Flash was more than just a young prodigy.
He went on a record-setting period of dominance in the months after his first OSL win in 2008.
And that wouldn’t be the last record he set.
Flash was so good that he almost single-handedly skewed the Proleague results between SKT and KT.
Where SKT dominated early bouts between the rival organizations, KT routinely got the
upper hand prior to the release of Starcraft 2 and the end of KeSPA-era Brood War.
KT won Proleague in the 2009-2010 season and in the 2010-2011 Season, beating SKT to do
it both times.
And though SKT did manage to topple KT in 2011-2012 Season 1, Flash’s dominance in
the OSL, MSL and other individual competitions could not be matched.
But by 2012, the Korean esports scene was changing dramatically.
The release of Starcraft 2 in July 2010 saw a shift in the community.
And though many players continued to play Brood War, the new blood and major international
esports dollars flowing into SC2 divided the scene.
There was one other factor: League of Legends.
Though the game had been out for some time in the West, the release of a Korean server
was a watershed moment for LoL.
And, with the time of Brood War beginning to wane, both KT and SKT made the jump to
League of Legends in late 2012.
KT created KT Rolster A and B, while SKT acquired a roster that would go on to become SK Telecom
T1 #1 .
In February 2013, SKT created their second team, SK Telecom T1 #2 (later T1 K), which
they built around a promising rookie named Lee “Faker” Sang-hyeok.
KT were quick to make a name for themselves, with a strong showing in Champions Winter 2012-13.
And both orgs put up strong results in the Spring.
But they were both on the upswing and by Summer 2013, KT and SKT were the teams to beat.
Faker had matured since his rookie tournament, and was beginning to make a case for himself
as one of the best players in the world.
And the Bullets’ talent-filled roster also boasted players who were beginning to cement
their legacies.
And on a rainy day in August, in a huge field near the Jamsil Olympic Stadium in Seoul,
the two orgs clashed in the finals for the first time in League.
Though SKT had individual star power, KT were seen as having stronger team play.
And they got off to a strong start,
(Casting)
But SKT didn't back down.
It all came down to a pivotal Game 5.
With both Faker and Ryu blind-picking Zed, KT managed to get a small lead early.
(Casting)
But SKT would not be denied.
And just past the 30-minute mark, SKT’s first Champions title was all but secured.
(Casting)
But Faker, wasn't done.
The most famous outplay in the history of League was the icing on the cake for SKT.
And they completed the reverse sweep, in what went down as one of the greatest series of
League ever played.
It was a new game, but for the rival orgs, there were shades of Brood War’s early days.
KT were good.
But not quite good enough.
Because of the way Worlds seeding worked at the time, second place was not good enough
to secure KT a berth to Worlds.
Worlds that year was SKT’s to win.
And, though they still had their doubters...
"All aboard the Korean hype train, SKT T1 for the championship hands down. I've got my tickets here.
I've got tickets to the Korean hype train. And I will be giving them out."
"Oh thank you Monte I appreciate you're like you're SKT favourite but I think it's...
or time for a revolution!"
"Thanks coach. No thanks. I'm going with Royal."
"I'm going to have to go ahead and choose Royal as well."
...Royal Club were no match.
(Casting)
SKT returned home victorious and unstoppable.
They didn’t drop a single game in the Group Stage of Champions Winter.
They swept Samsung Blue in the quarterfinals, and secured a rematch against the Bullets in semis.
This time it wasn’t close.
(Casting)
SKT swept their rivals and cruised through the finals as well, completing what is still
the only perfect season in Korean League history, going a combined 15-0 across six series.
If KT had dominated the end of Brood War, this new game, this new era, was SKT’s to claim.
They had the best player in the world, and a strong enough lineup to crush the game’s
toughest competition.
League of Legends was theirs to dominate.
Until it wasn't.
"Interesting to note that K has looked shaky in the past couple of weeks. I mean as shaky as they've ever looked
I should say."
"Well they looked lazy in their match against Optimus."
"I feel like Faker's picks, have been a bit cocky.
"Fear in the eyes of Faker, that is terror right there."
"I can't believe we're seeing, SKT K lose a game here.
"Or a team that didn't lose any games for an entire tournament last season."
2014 was a rough year for SKT, especially the T1K roster.
They placed Top 8 in both Spring and Summer, but losses in the Regional Finals saw them
fail to qualify for Worlds.
Meanwhile, the T1 S roster, featuring the likes of MaRin, Easyhoon, Bang and Wolf, finished
fourth in the Summer Split.
Both KT rosters were also unsuccessful in the Regional Finals.
There was no question Faker was a strong player, or that KT could compete.
But to some, it seemed like the Telecom teams’ time had come and gone.
League was still relatively young, especially compared to the lifespan of Brood War in Korea.
But with an explosion of esports worldwide, and the existing talent pool in Korean orgs,
the scene had matured quickly.
"And that's really what separates Korea as a region from a lot of the other regions.
"We're trying to get there infrastructure wise. But they have multiple sets of coaches."
"The Korean teams they know exactly how to punish mistakes, can
Taipei do the same, can Fnatic, can Cloud9 do the same thing here."
Some analysts still see 2014 as the most competitive year in Korea’s history.
And it seemed like the game was entering a new era, one dominated by Samsung.
But it didn’t happen that way.
With a huge influx of money into the Chinese scene, all 10 of Samsung’s starting players
were spirited away by lucrative contracts.
Many other players departed for other regions, which at the time could offer contracts larger
than many Korean orgs.
Dubbed the Great Korean Exodus, it remains the single greatest redistributing of talent
in the game’s history.
2015 saw other changes, with the abolishing of sister teams and a move towards a league
system, rather than the tournament format Champions had been running since 2012.
Between an amalgamation of talent onto single rosters and the departure of some of the region’s
most dominant players, it was a reset for the scene in many ways.
And both SKT and KT looked to capitalize.
"SKT T1. An organization that won Season 3 Worlds. And they still do have Bengi and Faker
so two of that Worlds team roster is still on this."
"KT looks like they finally gone with their starting lineup and that will be Score in the jungle.
and of course with Score's progress in the jungle it should be very exciting to see those games."
A  new force on the scene, the GE Tigers, topped the regular season.
But SKT’s new, combined roster, featuring MaRin, Bengi, Easyhoon, Faker, Bang and Wolf,
was too much come playoff time, and they swept the finals.
(Casting)
KT didn’t make playoffs.
SKT stumbled at MSI, but regrouped in time for summer.
In playoffs, hungry for another domestic title, a surging SKT and KT met in the finals for
the first time since Summer 2013.
"So exciting because of the stories of these organizations. SKT vs KT,
it's been a decade of rivalry between these two organizsations across games."
"And we have what I consider to be the best best of five ever played in League of Legends history
in Summer 2013."
But in the end, KT were no match.
The rest of the year and 2016, along with much of 2017, would be about one team and
one team only.
"SK Telecom!"
"SKT will be your first ever, two-time world champions!"
SKT 3-0's them in the playoffs on their way to their 2016 Spring title.
(Casting)
By Summer 2016, people were starting to think of the Telecom War as just a remainder of
a bygone era.
The fans KT earned with their showings in 2013 and 2014 had become a punchline.
To be a KT fan was to know heartbreak.
(Casting)
But after fighting their way to the second round of playoffs that summer.
KT earned themselves another crack at the unassailable SKT.
"It is definitely going to be a barn burner, very exciting KT looking to make their fourth consecutive summer final."
"SKT trying to keep their streak of victories alive ever since we went into the League format."
"They have yet to lose a season. First place every
single time."
This time, it was SKT that went up 2-0.
But with echoes of their 2013 final, KT brought it back to game 5.
And this time, it was enough.
(Casting)
KT weren’t able to defeat the ROX Tigers in finals. And, in classic KT fashion,
they missed out on Worlds, while SKT managed to become the first team to defend their world title.
KT fans were exuberant for one glorious day but their win was still a footnote on the year.
2016 still belonged to SKT, in the end.
KT fans tasted what it was like to topple their demons.
And the organization wanted more. So, in 2017, they returned to their early Brood War roots.
If SKT was a problem, they would bring in the best talent the world had to offer in an attempt to defeat them.
"I mean let's be real how many teams in the world, do you not look at every role and be like oh I'd take the
KT Rolster player over you. SKT maybe? Apart from that not many teams."
Smeb. Score. Pawn. Deft. Mata. Five of the best players to ever touch the game.
KT had crafted the roster to topple SKT.
They had crafted it to win.
WIth the return of former Samsung players to Korea, and the proven dominance of Smeb
and Score in their positions, it seemed like KT’s 2017 roster was too good to fail.
But it didn’t work.
KT Made it to the finals in the spring split, but were toppled 3-0 by SKT.
(Casting)
In the summer split, in Round 3 of the playoffs SKT won a closer series 3-2.
SKT won all four of their regular season meetings.
Then, KT missed out on Worlds, yet again.
KT built their team to defeat SKT, but they couldn’t shake their demon.
They were good in 2017.
But they were not good enough.
Of course, at the end of the year, neither was SKT.
(Casting)
Fans saw 2017 as a failure.
Despite results that would be incredible for another team.
And SKT’s 2018 spring split was inauspicious at best.
After struggling to find a version of their roster that worked for much of the regular
season, they managed to narrowly qualify for playoffs.
But, for once, KT entered playoffs with the upper hand.
For once, KT had the head-to-head during the regular season.
For once, KT were the favorites.
KT’s season ended in defeat at the hands of the Afreeca Freecs.
But even though they haven’t won a domestic title since 2014, they proved that, with a
little help from new additions Ucal and Rush, their roster can do what it was built to do
win the Telecom War.
(Casting)
SKT and KT’s rivalry has taken different shapes
in different games.
Generations of players and coaches have played their part.
But each time their players sit down in front of a keyboard to play, there’s something else there.
An extra boost pushing them to play their best — to be better, always better.
In the end, their position in one split, or in one tournament, doesn’t matter.
Fans will still pack the studio when it's time for KT and SKT to face off.
They’ll still scream “Fighting!” when the game begins.
And they will still roar with pride when their side is victorious.
KT Rolster and SK Telecom have been jockeying for position in esports for nearly as long
as esports have existed.
Both sides have won skirmishes, both sides have triumphed in battle.
But the Telecom War is far from over.
"SK Telecom!"
"KT Rolster!"
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.